okay so the topic of today's video is
cell history we'll talk about these
three fellows in a little bit so let's
get started
okay so when we today when we say
statements like you know all life is
made from at least one cell today that's
pretty straightforward but there was a
time when this wasn't well understood it
took the invention of the microscope for
cells to even be discovered to for us to
know that they even existed and we can
trace this back to 1665 this man right
here Robert Hook he was really the first
to observe cells underneath the
microscope when he examined Quark cells
which is simply just really dead tree
bark
and by the way here's a fun little
backstory this picture right here most
likely not even a picture of Robert Hook
no known portraits have survived over
time because he was in a feud with this
man right here you might recognize this
as Isaac Newton when Robert Hook died
Newton destroyed all known portraits and
paintings of Robert hooke's we don't
really know what Robert Hook looked like
but you can't erase the contribution
that Robert Hook had in biology so what
he did what Robert Hook did was he
examined cork which is really just the
bark of this type of oak tree right here
if we zoom on in
this is Robert hooke's hand-drawn image
of cork from 1665. and all those boxes
those little cubes that you see those
are the Quark cells now these cells are
dead that's why they all look empty they
don't you're not going to see any
nucleus or mitochondria or any other
parts of the cell these Quark cells the
only thing you're able to see is the
outer cell wall all the other parts of
the cell have deteriorated and
decomposed and all we can see is the
cell wall
and Robert Hook talks about how these
little boxes reminded him of tiny rooms
and another name for tiny rooms of
course are cells so as the years and
decades and centuries go by we discover
more and more about cells let's talk
about the next stage
so as time passes eventually something
called the cell theory develops and the
cell theory has three parts well first
of all let's talk about the gentleman
here the guy in the left Matthias
schleiden is a botanist and he studies
plants and he notices that every single
sample of plant that he examines plants
are made from cells the gentleman on the
right this is Theodore Schwann he's a
physiologist he's studying animal
samples and he realizes hmm all animals
are made from cells so combine these two
and it's really that all organisms are
made from at least one single cell
so the next part of the cell theory that
develops is that the cell is the most
basic unit of life now when you look in
this picture you can see cells have
smaller parts mitochondrion nucleus
rough ER so why is the cell the basic
unit of life why not the smaller parts
well the simple answer is the cell is
the most basic unit because it's the
smallest part that can still carry out
in the processes of life lysosomes
cannot function on their own neither can
rough yards and smooth er's but the cell
can so even though they're smaller parts
the cell is the most basic unit that can
carry on the processes of life
and the final part of the cell theory
that cells come from other cells well
here's a diagram of a cell cells don't
just poof
and now those two cells they go through
a dividing process and you know Rudolph
virtual this German doctor here he
really concluded that cells come from
pre-existing cells they go through a
dividing process called mitosis on the
far left this is one cell and then it
goes through the process of mitosis to
divide itself into two cells they don't
just poof into existence they go through
this division process
now that brings up an obvious whole and
or problem in this Theory and that's you
know where and how did the first cell
ever come from
like Rudolph virtual is saying right now
you know that's a good question science
does not really have a good
understanding of how life on Earth began
there are obviously philosophical and
religious views about how life began but
from science the scientific perspective
this is really viewed as like the
mystery of mysteries how did Life Begin
the search continues
okay let's talk about cells and their
diversity now here's a stereotypical
biology textbook maybe on this page
there's a diagram a square-shaped
diagram of a plant cell and on this page
maybe a round diagram of an animal cell
pretty much all biology books are guilty
of doing this a square shape for a plant
cell a round shape for an animal cell
but the reality is much different cells
are incredibly diverse
and so for example here's a picture of a
nerve cell also called a neuron now you
can see the shape with the elongated
branches it almost looks like a tree
with branches and roots coming off in a
variety of directions well this is
because the shape helps the performance
function which is the send electrical
messages and electrical signals to and
from the brain
you know here's an analogy right here
here's a map of the United States and
the lines represent major highways
across the country and so the red line
that's Interstate 80 it runs east and
west across the United States
if I ask myself could you get from could
you drive from City a to City B if
Interstate 80 were suddenly closed I
hope you see the answer is yes most
definitely you just have to take a
different route now the red line
Interstate 80 is the most direct route
but you could zigzag up and down and
around and eventually still get from
City a to City B now the analogy is like
the branches on a nerve cell
let me come back to this picture here
the branches send signals all around the
body and so this helps and AIDS the
function of a nerve cell because of some
of those branches are damaged well then
hopefully the signal can still travel
during uh travel through other branches
and arrive at the destination and so the
many many branches that you see are
actually an advantage to help the cell
performance function
and this is kind of a main idea here is
that the shape of a cell is related to
the function that the cell performs
another example of how diverse cells are
let's look at red blood cells you can
see that they're round and disc like in
their shape well here's a vein and when
we talk about the function of red blood
cells their function is to carry oxygen
throughout the body red blood cells have
this Round Disc like shape and you can
really see their advantage I hope it
helps them roll through the twists and
turns of the narrow veins and arteries
that stretch all throughout the body
so yet another great example of how the
shape of a cell is related to the
function that it performs
another example of the diversity of
cells here's a skin cell skin cells like
the ones in this picture here are are
flat and Broad and they cover a lot of
area when you think about the function
of skin cells which is to cover and
protect the body keep things out that
need to stay out keep things in that
need to stay in and so an advantage of
the skin cells being Broad and flat is
they overlap and they cover more area to
achieve their purpose of covering and
protecting the body in an analogy would
be like roof shingles or roof tiles so
here's a roof and you know when it rains
the water just slides down the roof
tiles and the shingles and keeps the the
elements outside of your house
again another great example of how the
shape of a cell is related to the
function that it performs
so let's talk about the two categories
of cells next the first category being
the prokaryotes these are the cells that
lack a nucleus and other membrane-bound
organelles a lot of organelles you
probably are familiar with they don't
have they don't have a nucleus they
don't have mitochondria they don't have
chloroplasts they don't have lysosomes
and so these are very primitive very
ancient organisms these are actually the
oldest organisms that science has ever
identified on Earth their fossils go
back about three and a half billion
years ago these rock formations known as
stromatolites these are rock formations
created through the actions of these
ancient prokaryotes here they're the
oldest evidence of life on Earth you
know the prokaryotes that's kind of
their fancy name but you probably know
these as bacteria and so microscopic
bacteria are prokaryotic organisms
so here's a fun analogy I hope you know
here's two cars they're both cars
they're both going to get you safely to
your destination but these cars are by
no means equal the car on top is very
primitive it's got no air conditioning
no leather interior no sunroof no radio
it's a stick shift no cruise control but
the car on the bottom has all the luxury
options the car on top the analogy is
that this is a prokaryote and the car on
the bottom the analogy is that this is a
eukaryote a more complex car and a more
complex cell let's talk about this more
let's look at the eukaryotes these are
the more complex cells these are these
are the cells that have a nucleus and
membrane-bound organelles when you look
at the list right here you might
recognize a lot of these from middle
school the mitochondria and the nucleus
and a vacuole and Golgi bodies and rough
ERS and smooth ers
these are again just a lot more complex
cells we believe that eukaryotes evolved
from prokaryotes
and if we try to explore how that
happened you know here's a drawing of a
large prokaryotic cell the theory known
as endosymbiosis you know this is the
theory of how prokaryotes We Believe
slowly evolved to become eukaryotes well
here's a smaller prokaryote and you can
imagine the scenario where this larger
prokaryote swallows up the smaller
prokaryote most likely for a food source
but uh for whatever reason the smaller
prokaryote is just not destroyed and
it's kept inside and over time the two
become so dependent upon one another
that the the smaller one actually
becomes a working organelle inside of
the larger one and over the millions and
millions of years as this continually
happens from ancestor to ancestor the
organelles pile up and build up and
build up eventually you can see this
wouldn't even qualify as a prokaryote
anymore this would qualify now as a
eukaryote because it has these
membrane-bound organelles that it's much
long ago ancestors lacked so this is one
way this is the way how we think
prokaryotes eventually evolve into
eukaryote excuse me eukaryotes and
eventually evolved from prokaryotes
and so these are the other forms of life
the other four big categories of of or
kingdoms of life on Earth members of
Kingdom Protista like this amoeba
members of kingdom fungi fungi like
these mushrooms members of Kingdom
plantae like this flower and members of
Kingdom animalie like this frog
so why are cells so small why are they
microscopic well
there's an easy answer to that the easy
answer is that smaller cells are much
more efficient at moving molecules in
into them and moving molecules out of
them cells generate waste and they have
to get rid of the waste cells have needs
and they need nutrients they need to
bring nutrients in and it's just a lot
more efficient when the cells are
smaller that's the easy answer
the harder answer is that smaller cells
have a greater surface area to volume
ratio so we're going to do a little bit
of math here
and so let's look at the surface area
the total area of let's say the cell
membrane here here's two cells a small
cell cell a and a larger cell cell b
let's calculate the surface area of cell
a
well first of all surface area is the
length times the width times the total
number of sides so let's just pretend
nice round numbers here the length is
two micrometers the width is two
micrometers and this Cube has six sides
so the surface area would be two
micrometers times two micrometers times
six sides is 24 micrometers squared
now let's do the same thing for cell b
again let's use nice round numbers here
let's pretend that the uh the length is
four micrometers and the width is four
micrometers and it two has six sides so
the surface area comes out to be 96
micrometers squared
well that's the surface area and now we
need to calculate volume
and so volume is really just the size of
the cell and you might know from maybe a
physical science class maybe from middle
school that volume is length times width
times height where I already have the
length and the width shown let me add
the height let's use nice round numbers
let's make the height two micrometers so
the volume of cell a is just 2
micrometers times two micrometers times
two micrometers which would be eight
micrometers cubed let's do the same
thing for cell b I already have the
length and the width let's make the
height again nice round number of four
micrometers and so the volume would be
four micrometers times four micrometers
times four micrometers which would be 64
micrometers cubed
but again where it says hard answer we
have to calculate the surface area to
volume so in order to calculate the
surface area to volume we just have to
divide the surface area by the volume in
cell a when we look at the surface area
of value we just divide the 24 by 8 and
you notice you come up with the number
of three
for cell b the bigger cell we divide 96
by 64 and you come up with one and a
half notice the smaller cell has a
greater number 3 is a bigger number than
one and a half so cells that have a the
greater surface area to volume ratio the
bigger the number is cells are just much
more efficient at moving molecules in
and out in cells that are small tend to
have much larger surface area to volume
ratios so larger cells like cell b would
struggle at moving molecules in and
moving molecules out of themselves that
they probably wouldn't survive
here you have a quick history on cells I
hope you liked this video if you're in
my class try to answer these questions
and I'm happy to check your answers
before class or after class one day
thanks for watching